- San Francisco's known for coffee, right?
- Right.
- Specifically, like, meets coffee
which is probably like an expresso bar,
or stuff like that.
- You're saying "expresso"?
There's no "k" in it.
It's just espresso.
- What, there's "k" offee in it.
- Espresso A-Go-Go in
San Francisco Co. 2K15.
You said expresso.
- ♫ Expresso, A-Go-Go,
In San Francisco Co.
♫ 2K15 ♫
- Before we go off
tasting in San Francisco
we decided we need to figure
out what makes coffee good.
- Cause we don't know
what makes coffee good.
- 'Cause we're idiots.
- And we don't know much about expresso.
- It's espresso.
Can I ask you questions about espresso?
So what should we be looking for?
- Aroma, acidity, boom, it has to hit you.
Espresso's got a lot of body to it, right?
That wow factor, delivery of adventure.
- Is there ever like a sex appeal
to an expresso shot?
- Oh yeah daddy.
- Cool.
- I think we got it.
- That was great.
- ♫ Can't stop having fun ♫
- Are we really gonna just
walk around San Francisco all day?
Yeah, we're used to Los Angeles,
where we just get to drive around, so.
Maybe we can figure out an alternative.
- Like a fun alternative.
- Like a fun, little, yellow alternative.
- So the first place--wup.
- So the first place we're
headed to is Starbucks.
God damn it, Brent's calling me.
- Espresso A-Go-Go in
San Francisco Co. 2K15.
Ahhh!
- Hello, we're going to Starbucks.
- We can park it like a car.
- "You guys aren't even allowed in here."
Oh.
- Oh well, thanks anyway.
- We're definitely not
supposed to be allowed to come
to this Starbucks.
Whatever.
Can I get a water and
two expressos to go go?
This is what it looks
like inside of the cup.
- Find out its aroma.
Chocolatey, burnt.
- A little bit of coffee.
- Three notes, OK.
Cheers.
Oh, it's awful.
If this was a person,
it would be a very out
of shape, angry person.
- It kinda tastes like acid.
- Every sip is worse.
- If this is my sense of adventure.
This is gonna be a bad trip.
- Well, this is my first expresso ever.
- Espresso.
- Yeah.
- Let's hope for better on the
- [Together] Espresso A-Go-Go
In San Francisco Co. 2K15.
- ♫ I'm puttin' tiny beans
and I'm grounden' em up
♫ I put em into a cup
♫ and I fill it with hot water
♫ and the filter it drips
♫ and it droppety drips
♫ and I take-a de sip
♫ and I give it a judgement
- ♫ I'll buy any espresso
♫ no matter the cost
♫ I'm lookin' down on my phone
♫ 'cause we straight-up lost
♫ Well, not that lost,
we're just hidden in a park
♫ but together we'll
make a bunch of sparks
♫ buncha fire
♫ spit fire
♫ tell you that you should desire
♫ oh we'll rap for Brent to catch up
♫ pourin' the coffee right into a cup ♫
- I just can't believe this is a thing
they let tourists just drive around.
Seems like a hazard.
Nice, we're at Peet's Coffee.
- It's a grocery store
but I think there's a Peet's inside.
Hey, could I get two espressos to go go?
- Smell?
I'm really only gettin'
chocolate and coffee.
- There's something like
kinda muddy about it.
- Maybe a little mint.
- Four notes.
(whistles)
What about the impact?
It was like a crescendo not an accent.
- It was like oooohhhh, OK.
This is a nice thick-bodied woman.
- Not basic at all.
- There's not a lot of base to it.
- I wish we had a litmus paper.
The sense of adventure.
This is a boat tour.
- Yeah, it's like having
a fun time with your mom.
- Does it get a sexy nod?
No.
Is it attractive?
Yeah, like a mother is.
- Overall, we'd say Pete's
coffee is the mother to this
- [Together] Espresso A-Go-Go
in San Francisco Co. 2K15.
- Thanks, mom.
- It's "espresso."
- ♫ Espresso A-Go-Go
in San Francisco Co. ♫
♫ We're cruisin' around
in a tiny little car
♫ having little cups of coffee
and we're doin' it far ♫
This is our first drinking taste buds.
- Oh.
Can I get two shots of espresso to go go?
- Yeah, aw yeah.
Reveille Coffee Co.
It's a Co! San Francisco Co.
- San Francisco Co.
It smells like chocolate chip ice cream.
- And it smells like
nature a little bit, too.
Marshmallow.
- I'd say at least five notes.
Ooohh!
- Im-pact!
I went through three
tastes in that first sip.
It's got a light body to it.
- I'm a like that light body is bangin'.
- This is so acidic.
This is like drinking a sour juice.
- I feel like I just got Bryn.
- "Yeah, sometimes you just that first sip
"and you're just like woah, I'm there."
And I'm like, what are you talking about.
And then this, I'm there.
- It's all over your mouth.
It's a totally different experience
tasting something like this.
- The sense of adventure,
I feel like I just left on a voyage.
- My mouth is now space.
Wow factor, absolutely.
- Ow, out of this world wow.
This almost makes me aroused.
I'm happy to give this my sexy nod
because I'm blown away.
- I feel more fun than sexy.
- I feel like this is erotic.
Espresso A-Go-Go in
San Francisco Co. 2K15.
- I'm havin' a blast, yo.
I'm in the Castro.
Blow your ass away, you asked, though.
You asked for it, I gave it to ya.
You got a question, I got a pregunta.
- ♫ On the west coast,
where the beaches are
♫ and we're lookin' 'round
callin' "where's our beaches at?"
♫ We're havin' so much fun
♫ we don't surf or nuttin'
♫ we just drive around in
cars and have fun for fun
♫ and we doin' it, we're doin' it,
♫ we're doin' it all day
♫ and we're having fun
♫ and we're totally friends
♫ and we're having a good time.
- Thanks, man.
- I don't know what the spoon is for.
- Four Barrel.
- Smells really good.
You got a little bit on your nose.
- Wood candy or something.
- It's like a corn sweetness.
- It's like a sour
patch, like Nilla Wafers?
Yeah, cheers.
Is it weird that my first
inclination is a color?
- Oh yellow.
- I would say like yellow-green.
- Body.
Look at it, it looks like a map.
I feel like this is
the most acidic so far.
- But it's almost like there
should be a different word
for this taste that we don't know yet.
- Dark sour.
- It's like a riddle of an adventure
'cause you're like
trying to figure it out.
- It's like down a rabbit hole.
I give this the wow factor
'cause I'm boggled.
- It's like the new Kendrick Lamar album.
You gotta listen to it over and over again
to really get it.
- There's a dog nearby.
- You know, the more and more I drink
I realize how shitty
the Starbucks one was.
You know what I wanna do, though?
We went in Blue Bottle.
We met Bryn.
Bryn taught us about coffee.
He showed us their coffee.
We went around the city
but we never tried Blue Bottle's espresso.
- Right.
- I feel like we should go
back and give that a try.
♫ Everywhere you look, everywhere,
♫ There's a heart, there's a heart
♫ A hand to hold on to
♫ Everywhere you look ♫
- It sounds like this car
is working really hard.
- Uh oh.
- What?
- This is full throttle right now.
- Oh, shit.
- Oh no.
- Here, wait, wait,
you're gonna pull over over there, ready?
Alright, no problem, everything's good.
Car's dyin'.
Call Brent.
- [Phone] Hello?
- Hey, uh, we just broke down.
No, we're just gonna go return it
because we're worried.
Can you hear me?
Hello.
Should we try again?
- What could possibly go wrong?
- Ready?
- Yeah, now see if it moves.
We're good.
- We're back going
at the Espresso A-Go-Go
in San Francisco Co. 2K15.
We're back, baby.
- Don't run over that.
- Don't run over what?
(clanking)
- That.
- Oh.
- Espresso A-Go-Go in
San Francisco Co. 2K15.
- This is where it said to drop it off.
- It all comes full circle.
- It's where we began,
it's where we're gonna end.
- On the Espresso A-Go-Go--
- Do it again, do it again.
- [Together] Espresso A-Go-Go
in San Francisco Co. 2K15.
- So we're back at Blue Bottle.
- We did it.
- A bunch of wonderful people
met up with us from Twitter.
- Twit-tar.
Oh wow.
It's OK, it's just Marilyn Monroe-ing.
So, uh, let's take a sniff.
- We're trying to figure
out how many notes.
- Yeah, sort of chocolatey.
- Kinda nutty.
- Any other note?
You really gotta--
- Well, espresso's like really bitter.
- Impact is our next test.
Ooh.
- That's when you're on a roller coaster
and it does the--
you sort of fall, but oh you didn't,
and then you fall, right?
You know?
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- What about the body?
- It's like soft skin.
- Silky.
- Yeah.
- It's like the girl
from the Your Body Is a Wonderland video.
- The acidity is like, it's there, right?
- Yeah, it's not like it's flying hard.
It's like those love boat
rides where you drive in
and it's like kinda dark and you're like
"I don't know about this,"
and then all these things
start scaring you and like.
- What scares you on a love boat ride?
- I don't know, man, commitment?
Overall, Blue Bottle gets a wow factor,
and Bryn gets a wow factor as a sensei,
as an espresso sensei.
- It's OK, you feel free to walk through,
this is just a street.
This is just a street.
Are you giving this your sexy nod?
Or are we just gonna give it to Bryn?
- I think I'm gonna give Bryn my sexy nod.
- Bryn gets it.
- An intellectual sexy nod.
- Oh my, and on physical,
I'll give it to him.
- OK.
It's been a good day.
Full of passion.
And you know, not only
did we sense adventure,
we had an adventure on the
- [Everyone] Espresso A-Go-Go
in San Francisco Co. 2K15.
- It's "es-presso".
- Yeah, expresso.
- Espresso!
- I thought it was
supposed to be expressive.
- Hey Chris, how do you feel
at the end of the night of the day
that we did the coffee video?
- I feel terrible.